[Music]
a certified avalanche dog like tally can
do the work of about 30 rescuers in the
same amount of time
their sense of smell is 10 times greater
than ours and if someone's buried in the
snow or not even buried but just lost in
the woods the dog can smell their scent
coming up through the snow pack and tell
me where to start digging to find that
person
we are the first responders and a lot of
times if things go
well into our training we can facilitate
that rescue without putting anybody else
in harm's way and be done quickly and
efficiently and all go home safely we
gotta find somebody i know you wanna
find somebody okay let's go search
[Music]
my name's hunter mortensen i'm an
avalanche technician here at
breckenridge ski resort with my ski
patrol partner tally and we've been
working here for eight years together
we're really fortunate here at
breckenridge we have six avalanche
rescue dogs on staff today tally's
hearing with her co-workers and friends
is boudreaux the golden retriever and a
up another mountain purebred mutt
the ears of the big saint bernard and
swiss mountain dog with the barrel under
their neck those dogs are built for the
mountains they're sturdy they're hardy
they can do it but what we're finding is
they don't travel well in the snow and
they're not as fast moving across the
snow and avalanche rescue's all a matter
of time so we're looking these days for
dogs that are a little bit on the
smaller side a little more nimble and a
little more quick
so the training we start him
six to uh nine months old and a lot of
it is just basic obedience and then we
start building from the obedience into
actual hide-and-go-seek type games and
then we build up from there into big
snow caves where we'll bury a person
almost six feet deep if we have enough
snow and then the dog will start
searching having to find where that
scent's coming up to play the game and
all they're really looking for is that
person who they think has their toy oh
that's a good girl
it's about two full years of training to
take your last certification test for an
avalanche rescue dog and handler so i'm
certified to work with tally
ready
my whole last eight years of my career
have been spent with her every day all
day when we have to do our thing we're
really dependent on each other
and i couldn't do what i do without her
and so it's an amazing partnership and
i'm really honored and proud to be a
part of this program and work with a dog
like her
[Music]
you